are we right are we ready to start
I'm Barbara Mead I'm one of the owners
of politics and prose I want to welcome
you all here this evening on such kind
of a dreary evening
but despite the dreariness this is
really fun for me to be able to
introduce David Brancaccio I was just
telling him I've seldom read the whole
book of an author that I'm introducing
but I did read his whole book and I
enjoyed it every page though I realized
that we're very very different
he's an oldest child he says by his
admission and he says that oldest
children are described in general to be
risk adverse I'm a second oldest child
and I tell you don't do not go into
business by yourself if you are
risk-averse I do have a partner and I
read the David's grandfather had told
him that you should always have a
partner well I do have a partner
unfortunately she's in Bali she's been
there the last three weeks she's not
helping me out very much I'm going to
get her to talk to David the minute that
she comes back David is going to talk
for about 20-25 minutes he'll then
answer questions and then we'll sign I
know that you're going to enjoy this
evening it's a delightful delightful
book and I thank him for coming
well good evening thank you for coming
on this awful awful night I was
wondering if anybody would show up but I
guess we're all trying to warm up by
snuggling up here together there's a
couple people in this audience who've
actually come to my office is a couple
people - you've worked in my office and
they know that when I say that working
at marketplace is like working in a
submarine that it's not an exaggeration
when I say there are no windows I don't
mean there are some windows with a lousy
view or a little bit if there are no
windows it's sealed it's hermetically
sealed and it gets you after a while but
also it's a problem for understanding
the world around you I don't have
Windows but we have all the other kind
of Windows Windows 98 lots of computer
screens with lots of wonderful readouts
from the market pumping in data from the
markets still warm
we have rolodexes with midnight phone
numbers of Wall Street analysts that
even their mistresses don't have we have
an incredible resource there of data if
you need any data call we'll gladly
furnish it to you but you get to a
certain point and you realize data is
not wisdom and you get to the point
where you're looking at a readout on say
Reuters from the lumber pits in Chicago
the commodities exchange and you'll see
a spike in the price of lumber and
you'll say well that's interesting as
abstract as that seems
and you won't know because there's no
windows that the reason that the price
of lumber is spiking is that there's a
wildfire that's roared out of the Malibu
hills and is headed burning toward the
front door of marketplace and our first
indication would be in this abstract
two-dimensional way so I want to get
some natural light and I want to get
some street smarts about some of this
money stuff if you take a look at the
flap of the book it says I have a BA in
history in African Studies and an MA in
journalism and no MBA whatsoever it says
now if you have any MBAs here
I'm not trying to be insulting
marketplace depends on the kindness of
MBAs we call for expert opinion also PhD
economists were not shy about consulting
but the folks who work on the show tend
to be generalists and journalists but
generalists typically liberal arts
humanities undergraduate backgrounds and
we place them on the business beat and
we're in a way like anthropologists on
the outside looking in because we don't
know where you're coming from listening
to the program you may be detailed see
section of the Wall Street Journal
readers or you may be an artist at a
potter's wheel just wanting to know how
you're gonna plan for your own financial
retirement I get asked all the time
sometimes in forums like this people
come up to me and they say it's very
natural question to ask they'll say
something like I've come into some money
there's been an inheritance or there's
been an insurance settlement or I got a
bonus or I sold a house at a profit or I
exercised some stock options fill in the
blank there's this lump sum and people
phrase it an interesting way they say
David what is the right thing to do with
it it's a loaded term right thing to do
with it and so for years I would laugh
off the question I would say before you
ask someone for their financial advice
find out how fancy a car they drive on
the premise that if you were so smart
you'd be rich I ride bicycle to work and
I work for a.org as you notice not a.com
and if I was so smart I'd be on the
Cayman Islands not singing for my supper
each evening of course a bit flip of an
answer needs to do better than that so I
wanted to get street smarts but it could
not math could not be involved
so I created an idea for a for a
personal finance book if you can call it
that or is it a road book is it
narrative travel but it is a book
clearly for people who had higher SAT
verbals than SAT math and I'll explain
where I went and how I got out on the
road in just a minute
but my reading of literature I sort of
read everything I could about the motif
of the crusade or the pilgrimage
I guess pilgrimage is a better term
their pilgrimage the quest that's the
word I'm groping for and to go out on a
quest you need a catalyst you need to
sign something has to happen and this
was the sign that was visited upon me I
was as I tend to writing my copy for
marketplace method close to the deadline
no sense in finishing early right
other things to do and so is about two
minutes before we went on the air the
first broadcast of marketplaces 2:00 in
the afternoon Pacific time five o'clock
here and then we'll fix it or update it
or make it fresher by the time it rolls
around here two minutes to air and I
walk over to the place with the hot
water to get some tea and I looked down
at the copy and I swear it says while
the Dow Jones Industrial Average was in
the dumps the Gnostic did better GN OST
I see the Gnostic so I blinked a couple
of times hoping that it would not really
say Gnostic because if it did I would
have to recuse myself from further
broadcasting duties by reason of
insanity but it said it said the Gnostic
trader is quoted as saying it went on
throughout the thing so I walked it ran
out of time I walked into the studio sat
down and there's a little intercom
button you can press to talk to the
producer of the show who's on the other
side of the double pane glass and I said
what is Gnostic mean and does Deborah
her eyes get very wide and she said
number one I don't know number two
you've got ten seconds number three
forget gnostic they'll think you mean
nasdaq a forensic reconstruction of what
has come down to us at marketplace as
the Gnostic incident blamed blamed pilot
error was a
mistake on my part we're part of the
University of Southern California and a
fairly green work-study student I had
asked to spell check my copy try this at
home
WordPerfect 7.0 and earlier changes
Nasdaq - Gnostic it really does now my
Greek is rusty but I knew that Gnostic
had something to do with knowledge it's
self knowledge really it's the kind of
knowledge that's more at home around the
word insight than it is around
curriculum or training and it was the
Gnostic incident that maybe realized you
know what one of the reasons that money
and what to do with money this question
sometimes seems so daunting is that we
need to have a better idea of who we are
before we can figure out what to do if
we're lucky enough to have a lump sum so
it's really almost an unanswerable
question when someone says what should I
do with money if you don't know that
person and I realized that one of my
problems was look weird what do I want
to be doing how it might I prioritize
those things and how can I have some fun
so I combed through newspaper clippings
and newspapers are diligent about
reporting one thing which is the lottery
press conference after a jackpot win why
they're compelling human stories lottery
also perhaps this is a bit cynical but
you know the lottery is a great
newspaper advertiser and so you comb
through the clippings and people say
what they want to do with their winnings
and they seem to fall into ten
categories really the obvious thing
someone wins the lot to go on a as we
say in New England a wicked shopping
trip want to go on a shopping spree so I
thought where in America can I examine
what the utility of that is what is the
return on investment of spending extra
money Mall of America outside
Minneapolis it's got a Camp Snoopy theme
park on the inside more visitors to the
mall than Disneyland and the Grand
Canyon combined and it went to not spend
to try to abstain to try to resist the
powerful forces that urge all of us to
part with the cash
that was the theory right but the mall
is very good at what it does and the
another problem is that my vow of
abstinence also meant that I didn't eat
and so you get about four or five hours
into this little ordeal and your blood
sugar drops and in my case when my blood
sugar drops he gets stupid and you start
making stupid connections and your logic
seems to fly out the window and at one
of these low blood sugar addled moments
I look down into my briefcase or
whatever I was carrying and there were
notes that I had prepared notes about
the mall I look in there there was a
familiar name this is in fact the case
who owns the Mall of America my
retirement annuity owns the Mall of
America so you see the conclusion right
away if all of us went around trying to
be aesthetic and not spending then the
mall would be hurt and if the mall is
hurt my retirement is hurt so clearly
one needs to get out there and spend
this is actually an interesting sort of
symbol of the conundrum should we spend
or should we save we were all and we the
president really was touting the longest
economic expansion in the history of
this country during peace or war time
February's the hundred and seventh month
the longest while he was giving that
press conference former Treasury
secretary Reuben was in London at the
London School of Economics saying we got
some problems we have debt and Americans
also don't save well are we supposed to
save or not when the global economy
seemed to melt down two years ago
starting an Asian spreading toward Latin
America it can be argued that American
consumer spending helped power the world
economy out of this funk on the other
hand imagine the innovation that could
spring from the investment dollars if
more of us were to say if it's an
interesting idea where else do people
say what else would they do with money
they say one fool said I've just won the
Powerball while I'm on a roll I'm going
to Vegas she said that so I went to
Vegas myself to assess my own sense of
risk as was just alluded to earlier here
you can't have any clue about what you
want to do with your money and how to
invest if you don't know how risk-averse
you are let's put that into plain
English the way
to do on marketplace what is this
risk-averse I'm talking about how sick
does it make you in your stomach if you
lose money or the related concept how
quickly we get thrown out of your house
by your significant other if you lose
money on a gamble that goes awry to
Vegas to examine this and I met some
very interesting people who taught me
that the what they call the gambling
markets inform my understanding of the
financial markets and here's a small way
met a guy in Vegas Edward Thorp a
University of California mathematician
says he's not a gambler but in 1957 he
went to Vegas stared at the blackjack
tables took his data back to like a
univac computer or something and came up
with beat the dealer the card counting
book from whence all other card counting
books descend and he's got a system he's
not just a mathematician he's a
wonderful calculator can do great sums
in his head and can really track with a
great degree of precision the
probabilities of what the next cards are
gonna be coming out of a six-deck shoe
in Vegas and he goes but even playing
perfect blackjack return on investment
is not huge it's 2 or 3% University of
California it's a state school didn't
have much of an it of a of a nest egg to
even start with he didn't like the the
cigarette smoke in the casinos the pit
bosses would get the cattle prod out if
they figured out what he was up to so he
quit that once he had mented that
through his blackjack playing his nest
egg and started a hedge fund in the
1970s and became fabulously wealthy so I
approached him I said gonna get into the
hedge fund first of all he's got a
million bucks ok next plan
he had alluded to the fact that his
daughter had just had triplets so I said
what is the secret to investing that you
can impart because you seem to have a
really good sense of whether or not you
can find little tidbits about the way
the market works that you can leverage
what is your investment advice to her
and he said well best I can tell her to
do is the best I can tell you to do if
you don't have the million for my fund
which is indexed mutual funds the most
boring plain vanilla does not get you a
date at a cocktail party strategy for
investment why because it only is the
market you can't beat the market with
there's a lot of things that recommend
that strategy Commission's are cheaper
because you computer runs that not a
highly paid investment professional but
there's a downside if we get some when
the indexes are down which someday will
happen as I mentioned it was a history
major as an undergraduate history tells
us there will be down years history
tells us the business cycle has not been
outlawed those funds could go down I've
been looking deeply into your eyes as
I've been talking to you and it's a
pretty big crowd tonight but I think I
think I can trust you with some very
sensitive information this is Washington
you know the rules off the record off
the record beans off the record that
means you can't repeat this outside of
the store why because it is information
so sensitive it will end life as I know
it it'll ruin my craft it's not a
profession my craft business reporting
if the word gets out I had heard talk of
some of this during my travels around
the country for squandering aimlessly
but no one would really weigh in on the
subject because it was so sensitive bond
bombshell stuff I called a buddy of mine
at a new york-based personal finance
publication and he Frost's over suddenly
it's I tell you but I'd have to kill you
kind of thing I get an envelope in the
mail though subsequently with a New York
postmark no return address I open it up
and it's a citation it's a reference to
an academic journal an obscure one
volume 53 number three of the Journal of
Personality and Social Psychology and I
found it at USC the library we're near
Market Place in the fourth sub-basement
I open to page 490 fully expecting it to
be razored out because of the powder-keg
nature of its findings it's there and
when I tell you the title you'll see why
we need to keep this under wraps here's
the title it's by Harvard social
psychologist Paul Andreessen the title
on the social psychology of the stock
market aggregate attributional effects
in the regressive miss of prediction
all right we write better headlines on
marketplace how's the way dude
he did tests on human subjects he he got
a bunch of graduate students divided the
group in half he gave both mock stock
portfolios to Trey
mock stock portfolios but half the group
he gave business news to radio TV print
the other half he did not he denied the
business news to which group did better
the group denied the good services of us
you know Here I am thinking the public
radio mission we're here to educate
we're a force for good and uh you know
an ocean of crass media where they're
trying to do the right thing do you see
what's on the nonfiction bestseller list
I'm dying to get this book up into that
list that we can knock a couple of
wrestlers out and realize I'd be part of
a culture war but Here I am
but why might this phenomenon have been
evidence there's no hard data but here's
a suggestion why might Business News be
bad for your health I'm ashamed to say
here's an idea let's say yahoo shares
are up four percent today it may be that
the real explanation is and you'll get
this if you call an honest Wall Street
analyst they'll say well I'll say sir
why is he ah who about four percent
he'll say sometimes the market goes up
sometimes the market goes down which is
true that's not good enough
I mean we're rationalist reporters try
to make sense out of the confusion the
buzzing confusion of the markets so we
will press the analysts and if the
animals can't do better than that we
will get ugly and use threats until
finally an analyst or will dig up one
will say well there is new information
about Yahoo's joint marketing
partnership I'm making this up with
Disney sounds good to me and I'll put it
on the air I'll be very earnest about it
and you'll believe me I'll say Yahoo
shares are up four percent today after
an analyst said that a new marketing
agreement with Disney it shows promise
and if you believe me maybe you might
act on that information you might buy
Yahoo because you think Lots new
information about the joint marketing
agreement in the Yahoo trend actually
Yahoo trend is altered slightly higher
and you might want to try to capture
that by buying conversely pick a stock
AOL AOL shares
down 5% today maybe they were just down
things happen in the market with so many
inputs not good enough analysts can be
cajoled to say something like insiders
at AOL are saying that the alliance with
Time Warner is about to fall apart and
so you'll believe me and you may sell
AOL what if I'm wrong but the analysts
are wrong well then the shares will seek
whatever mean that they were whatever
trend that they were on and Yahoo will
go back down to whatever it was and AOL
will go back up but if you acted on it
that's buying Yahoo on a peak and
selling AOL on a dip which is not the
road to riches in this business so why
do I do it when I take a stand
well old traditions die hard in business
reporting we try we try to write this
stuff with a certain degree of irony but
perhaps we don't emphasize it quite
enough you'll hear us say things like
one analyst had a cockamamie theory that
says this but sometimes stocks go up and
down we can't do that all the time and
sometimes there is information about a
company I mean I dare say that Microsoft
shares were down last Friday after that
Gartner group report said that there may
be problems compatibility problems with
Windows 2000 that's enough to get a
bunch of people selling so we make a
judgment call maybe we get it wrong but
related to this idea before we take
questions this idea of how the market
works in market psychology a Treasury
secretary Rubin when he was treasurer
stacker he came came to marketplace for
an interview want to talk about
funneling capital to solve inner city
problems after the marketplace interview
I talked to him and I said is there a
really cool war room over at Treasury to
deal with like a market crash you know
map of the world and glowing LEDs stuff
like that said now because we don't pay
attention of the market day to day and
you shouldn't either I said if the if
the Dow is down 900 points you won't
call anybody no one will call you he
said maybe someone will call but again
who cares day to day and I said you
suggesting sir that I should
not report the Dow Jones Industrial
Average each day and he said you were
the twinkle in his eye he said yes and
you'd be doing your listeners a service
so that night in honor of his eminence I
went on the air and didn't say the Dow
Jones Industrial Average but eight
minutes into our 28 minutes show I
started to shake about 22 minutes then I
broke on to this awful sweat I was fully
nauseous by 22 and by 28 of course I
caved it was up I tell you it was up and
he forced it out of me
again old habits die hard
lastly there was a narrative problem
with this book
originally I done the first draft of
this book and there was a problem I
hadn't carried an actual surplus around
the country and actually spent it would
have been great if it was real money
that would have put edge to this thing
it didn't happen I worked for public
radio I didn't have a nest egg what are
you gonna do but then a wonderful thing
happened I just finished the rough draft
and I was at the marketplace office
going through my mail throwing out all
the press releases without looking at
them as you do throwing out all the
boss's memos without reflecting on them
as you do and just throw the stuff away
great clumps and about the sixth clump
something caught my eye it was an
envelope with one of those windows in it
and in the window was my name
oddly spelled correctly well that's
interesting so I pulled out the envelope
and it's a good thing I did it was a
check to me for 40 $2,500 may I say that
again with feeling
$42,500 to me I had never seen a lump
sum in one place that large I had not
and it was a wonderful opportunity given
all the research I had done because
prior to my research running around the
country talking to Americans both the
humble and the great about had they ever
seen a surplus what have they done what
I could could they teach me about their
experience a check like that would have
put me off my food for weeks I would
have been sent into a spiraling funk or
something I mean that the possibilities
of a lump sum like
that are paralyzing but I knew exactly
what to do with a lump sum like that
$42,500 you can give it to public radio
I realize that you could contribute to
wamu you could contribute to wamu or
WETA at a membership level that you are
comfortable with and still have forty
two thousand four hundred sixty-five
dollars left over to squander now I want
to emphasize a little point to tell you
what I did do with that 42 five I'm not
saying that the great fruits of this
historic boom are distributed equally
although it was amazing how people even
if modest means had confronted lump sums
in their lifetimes not making that case
but I mean I am here to tell you that a
middle-class American family 42:5 not
that much money
not life changing really I can't tell
you what you do with the money here's
what I might do with the money if I was
trying to do something upstanding
responsible like what Ward Cleaver would
do something that make Kiplinger's here
tonight something that Kiplinger's would
honor me for do the right thing with the
money all right first thing top up my
401k plan there's a great investment
tax-free in my case that's you know
several thousand dollars more you could
probably wedge in there next thing
charity
I see charity as a chapter in the book
as part of a portfolio a part of asset
allocation for various reasons pay taxes
unavoidable and then you're left in the
low 20s already it's barely twenty
thousand so to make the other tough
decisions more palatable you gotta do
something a little fun so how about $500
for me $500 for my spouse that we don't
have to account to you about just have
some fun with and then you're left with
something sort of in the 18s 19's cut
that remainder in half 9,000 and change
in 9000 and change in our case start the
most pathetic wretched little education
fund for the three kids an education for
nine thousand change that's like one
semester tuition only at today's prices
for Nicholas forget about the other ones
and forget about the other three
half years but it's a start it should be
a lump sum that you could augment and
invest wisely maybe in the market long
term what our kids are still young stock
market and you're left with another
9,000 and change our house is small it
doesn't have a study there's no place
for Grandma and Grandpa when they come
visit come on grandpa here so this is
one of the options that I've been
sharing tonight maybe it's a the pays
the transaction cost most of the closing
costs on a new house how about that okay
then the money's gone it's all very
defensible but if I wanted to use a lump
sum like 40 to 5 to do something radical
in life changing I think I'd have to
prove that the money was really a
windfall in its true sense really money
unearned that just rained down on me
I stumbled across it so I called the guy
who sent me the check and said what's up
it was a mistake a horrible just hideous
ironic mistake given the topic of the
book but a mistake it was not for me
so when finally confronted with the
biggest windfall I'd ever seen in my
life having done two years worth of
research for just that eventualities
this is what I in fact did with it I got
out one of those indelible medium point
magic markers and wrote voi D across the
front
Thanks any questions
I'll um I'll repeat the question because
of its a big crowd and sir a prediction
we did I've seen studies of people who
make predictions thinking about
economics people who work renegade
independent economists tend to make more
rash predictions because the media never
holds them accountable if they turn out
to be wrong but will go to them and
celebrate them if they turn out to be
right Microsoft they got trouble
they got trouble and I think they're
planning for a breakup but I have no
idea well which way it's gonna go so
we're gearing up for coverage looking at
the different eventualities I think you
know I was a sucker for a long time
believing the Microsoft earnest
descriptions that they they're not in
trouble and then look what's happened so
far I think that that company has been
demonized I'm not saying they're a demon
but it has been effectively tarnished in
the minds of the public and I don't
think that there at the moment a
terrible political risk about going
after the richest guy in the world
and that's a populist way to look at it
I'd say it it's right but I think there
wouldn't be a vast public swell of
support to save Bill Gates's took us
that's my view it's kind of a little bit
outside my area though in the back do
you think that one of the reasons a lot
of the popular business news media
doesn't report that index funds are
really one of the wisest ways
large-cap investing is because it's
against their own interests in terms of
viewership or readership the question is
how come you don't hear about index
funds often enough and is it a plot by
the media to suppress the I'm
paraphrasing it it's not as fun but
what's fueling a lot of this interest in
portfolio management and running your
own portfolio is an earnest desire by
people to take control of their
financial destiny and not to get taken
by people trying to sell them something
that's inappropriate these are all good
things
what is also fueling this is the market
as sport and not even spectator sport
it's not like watching a hockey game
when you get down to the floor of the
New York Stock Exchange to look around
it's like being in the middle of a
hockey game and there is a tendency to
want to play the home version of
Jeopardy and you know what's a better
story I made a killing in Qualcomm or my
portfolio went up 21 X you know whatever
the doubt did last year or whatever the
S&P did last year which is pretty darn
good but you didn't beat the market so
it's not as fun and there's a whole
psychology that goes with confusing CNBC
for c-span up confusing CNBC for ESPN
you tend to you know you play it way
into the night and yeah commissions are
cheap but they're not cheap if you're
trading all the time and listen if
you're trading your account you know
there's there's controversial
marketplace had a piece of this last
night there is controversial new
research that suggests that the more you
trade the worse you do women trade a
little less aggressively the statistics
seem to indicate women do better than
men
the statistics seem to indicate but
listen you know if it's money you know
you know if it's money that it won't
affect the health of your family if you
lose and you can learn a lot running
your own portfolio fine and if the time
that you're spending fooling with your
portfolio every night is instead of
watching must-see TV more power to you
however if it is instead of reading to
your children at night I'm gonna call up
your ISPs and have them disconnect it
why did I make that comment it has to do
with my belief I think it's a thread
through squandering aimlessly that money
is not an end in itself the game is not
the end it's a means to something else
that you define yourself I mean just
trading because it's cool game that
seems a bit silly what do you want the
money for that you're trading for and
trying to augment that's the question to
ask man well your next book be about
book squandering aimlessly was was
driven by a real desire to try to
communicate an idea to educate about
some of these issues using a different
mode the next one's going to be a very
cynical marketing guided attempt to sell
you something and it won't be called
squandering aimlessly it'll be called
pandering shamelessly I don't know it's
so wonderful is wonderful now how's the
good part where I get to after toiling
away in private having people read the
book and sharing their reactions to the
book that's the good part the writing is
a complete nightmare
an editor once had an applicant at a
newspaper and she said the applicant
says to the editor I love writing and
his retort was you're either stupid or
you're lying I mean the actual process
of writing is not exhilarating the
finishing the writing is I'm a wannabe
photographer I tried to get some of my
photographs in this book it didn't work
out and hey wouldn't be a cool photo
book to do marketplaces of the world
defined very large you know African
marketplaces eBay if there's a there
there
I think you could do that right some
interesting essays because there's so
much where where where we determine
prices and interesting different ways
there's an idea
they haven't exactly come screaming
asking me for my next project a quick
history of marketplace public radio
sister didn't think there was room for a
business show in the eighties you know
it's kind of conservative business stuff
and we're all a bunch of groovy liberals
but we care that's a bit of a stereotype
but there was that Public Radio
International thought they could start
one and it went through different
iterations CBS produced it for public
radio for a while and it was very worthy
it sounded good but it's very stentorian
very CBS big deep-voiced announcers
talking about corporate earnings all the
time didn't seem to fit the station said
and so some iconoclasts my boss is jim
russell JJ you're got together and tried
this concept where to put it well
frankly the the first choice was not
here because last I checked you pretty
well represented in producing public
radio interesting wonderful programming
from here a next logical place New York
but the rest of the media's in New York
Chicago that's a place to put a new
business show it didn't work out that
way someone was building studios for a
different project in California there's
an economy of scale we piggybacked on
that and we say things we go around
saying things like our location on the
west coast gives us greater sensitivity
to Pacific trade issues listeners do say
that there's a certain California Janice
a qua about us maybe because we're
obnoxious or something but we like being
there we like being there we like not
going to the same parties as my
colleagues here just because it helps
bring a diversity a diverse nest to our
approach it was adopted in its first
year by the University of Southern
California there were some financial
problems early on and we're like a like
a little Institute at USC us he goes no
money whatsoever
we're so
supporting and you know the thing it's
corporate underwriting for part of it
and we charge the station's exorbitant
amounts of money to subscribe to us and
then they beg money from you actually
select the numbers music or the music in
general right yeah it's all me I'm like
I'm a Renaissance man no there's a
producer named Deborah Clark and if
anybody's so much as dreams of
suggesting music for the show she will
do deliberately just the opposite to
spite them so what I do and this is
actually true I sneak in on the weekends
I live close to marketplace I sneak and
I've keys and I put in extra music
bridges into the little digital device
that plays them and magically they seem
to creep on the air at appropriate times
I just heard the country one I stuck in
there the other day in the show I was
very pleased with myself for getting
away with something it's the producers
responsibility and I dare say some
people listen to mark a place for those
bridges we get a lot of people calling
asking and what was it and we we have a
list you take a couple more sir your
convertible on the cover and using
convertibles are good investments oh
yeah I don't own that car vintage cars
are a motif throughout the book I come
across them and they informed the
journey in different ways we needed a
car for the cover that was originally I
am told Jerry Lee Lewis his car bought
he bought three of them from the
proceeds of a we call it a windfall the
money from great balls of fire it's a 57
olds ninety-eight convertible he doesn't
own it now but we got from one of these
movie companies and I yeah we get to
drive for like a day but what a profit
is man last question I heard your
interview with cogent army of WaMu today
and I heard all this stuff
the second time actually one thing I
heard that you haven't I haven't heard
you discuss was you have a chapter on
socially responsible investing which I
applaud as one who likes to encourage
that among friends and colleagues and in
that regard and wondering if you've had
a piece on the radio or if you could on
the whole issue now so many people
who've made great paper profits from
investments that they bought low and
that are really just soaring through the
stratosphere and get tax deductions
beside by giving that to charities I
know here in Washington friend and I are
among the starters of something called
the Washington area Women's Foundation
which is like the elements but you may
know and others around the country that
does help women in here and girls and
we've been trying to encourage that and
I thought it's something that's a good
subject area yeah we try means
philanthropy really is seen as a core
issue on marketplace do we do it with
the same dedication that we cover you
know the markets probably not we try we
have had some stuff on gifting stock the
station's like it at the end of the year
because the station's get some of that
they actually encourage some listeners
to do that sort of thing public radio is
sort of a tertiary charity it's called
its hope that you'll give money to
something else first solve you know
hunger and then you can help the likes
of us I think that's why as you have two
chapters I have this chapter socially
responsible investment the subtitle is
invest like you're very liberal mother
is watching it's a bit unfair you can
screen a portfolio according to whatever
your values are there are conservative
Christian mutual funds that you can get
it's not just liberal stuff but there's
also a charity chapter and as again I
see as part of your approach of your
approach to investing you should think
about just the law right up there with
how much cash you have how much stocks
you have the interesting thing with
charity is especially with a lump sum
and this is a serious slightly cynical
point what happens when you win the
lottery they make you do a press
conference it's part of the contract
they'll give you this oversized check
and if you do come into some money other
people will find out as well even if
it's not the lottery and what happens
when everybody finds out that you've
gotten lucky or something good has
happened to you everyone that you so
much has been rubbed up against in a
crowd is gonna call asking you for a
piece of it I'm not even talking fraud
here I'm talking about people with
legitimate stories to tell about why
they need that money more than you and
you need an organized approach to this
you need to have figured out what your
priorities are so that you can have an
answer an organized answer and a
foundation or you know you give to this
particular area that particular area
otherwise it really will disappear and I
talked to Michael Moore the guy did
Roger and me TV nation got three million
dollars from Warner Brothers for Roger
and me what'd you do with the money
Michael he said a million went to taxes
a million went to set up a foundation
for the underprivileged people of Flint
Michigan who are the subject of that
documentary what'd you do with the last
million the only bad answer in this book
to what you do is money he said it kinda
just went away kind of went away now he
would led me to believe it's through
like fancy restaurant meals and you know
going to the mall
I sink what I heard from other people
was other people came up to him and
asked for bits of it for good things in
a willy-nilly fashion it wasn't
organized but I think that's you know if
money gives you power where is most of
our money in our portfolios leveraged it
one way or another to exercise that
power to do good I think that's a
reasonable listen thanks I'm gonna try
to sign some of these I appreciate you
coming
once again I want to thank David
Brancaccio for sharing his book with us
this evening this was a wonderful
evening David books are for